You're about to see how deep this rabbit hole go.
Hello world.
It's survived and freelancing keeps getting more and more popular as a career
option.
I'm going to explain how you can do freelance AI programming in this video.
I've done freelancing myself on and off for years when I was in college and in
between jobs.
It was an awesome way to make money as someone who came from a lower middle
class background,
making 80 to a hundred dollars an hour doing programming contracts was a big
deal for me and gave me the runway necessary to work on my own personal projects
as well as spend time traveling and learning.
I now earn revenue from a multitude of sources.
Youtube ads,
Patrion book sales,
my paid courses at the school of Ai and now that I built a recognizable brand in
the AI community,
companies like intel,
Google,
and Amazon consistently approached me to do sponsored videos.
Still no Microsoft though.
Being a freelancer is awesome.
You can live anywhere you want to.
I just spent an entire year living in Amsterdam before moving back to the
states.
Recently.
We work makes it easy to have an office in pretty much any major city across the
world and you won't have a traditional boss,
but it's not all roses.
It takes time to build a sustainable income.
There's a lot of competition out there.
You need to be very disciplined and it can be a somewhat lonely journey at least
at first because you're usually working by yourself.
With all that said,
the freelance workforce is accelerating and it's growth and almost half of all
millennials are now freelancing.
So now is the time to try it out.
If you never have before your first step in this journey,
it should be to make a game plan.
How much time per week do you have available to do freelance work?
Made sure to factor in lesser known tasks like time required for finding work,
learning about tools,
meetings,
and setting up your workflow.
Are you going to do this part time or full time?
What kind of projects interest you later on?
You can change your plan once you get started,
but this practice will help you frame your journey.
There's a lot to plan,
so don't take this step lightly.
Made sure to factor achievable weekly,
monthly,
and yearly goals into your schedule.
This will give your journey momentum as you achieve them according to a recent
study by upwork.
Ai Programming is one of the most in demand skills for freelancers.
So if you find AI interesting,
you are very lucky.
Also I love you.
Make a list of some of the subtopics in AI that excite you the most.
Then make a list of some of the most in demand AI skills out there like chat bot
development,
computer vision and tensorflow and see what the intersection between the two
lists are.
Once you've found that you know that type of skills you need to learn.
Learning by doing is the best way to learn anything and even though paid work is
the goal,
you can jumpstart your portfolio by contributing to open source projects on get
hub.
This is a great way to both improve your skillset and expand your network.
Muybridge publishes a monthly top 10 open source projects list on get hub that
highlights some cool machine learning projects you can contribute to.
And as you get to know other developers of the project via slack or get her
channels,
you'll learn more and expand your network of opportunity.
Also be sure to take advantage of all the incredible free machine learning
content that's available on the Internet.
I have some great curriculums and playlists to help guide you on your journey.
Links to those will be in the video description.
When you feel your skills are up to par,
that's when it's time to start the dance of finding clients.
One often overlooked group are your existing contacts.
Lots of successful freelancers get their initial work through friends,
family and acquaintances post on your social media channels that you are
available for freelance work and join some social groups on Facebook that act as
freelancer marketplaces.
You should create a list of platforms that you can browse to look for work.
There are the more popular ones like upwork and freelancer.com both of which I
have personally used to both fine and give work,
but there are also other lesser known ones like top,
top,
top tool,
pre screening applicants and is very selective.
But if you're accepted,
expect access to some world class job openings.
Another one is angel list.
Just use the filters,
data scientist and contract and you'll instantly find startups offering contract
work.
Founder dating is another.
It will connect you with entrepreneurs who need advisees.
Filter your search by those.
Looking for a background in data analytics.
guru.com is quickly gaining popularity as a job listing platform and we work
remotely.
Dot Com has a pretty slick interface which makes it fun to use.
Try to find the lesser known smaller job listing platforms on Google as those
have less competition,
which makes it easier for newcomers who don't have as established a reputation.
In addition to job listings,
real life events can act as networking opportunities to find potential clients.
Sites like Katie Nugget's,
O'Reilly Strada meetup and data science central offer networking events all
around the world for data science and you can be sure that people are looking
for talent will be attending these events.
You can connect with them in person there.
In my experience in person meetings definitely help build trust faster,
which is crucial and you'll definitely want to bring some business cards with
you linked to a great service for that in the video description.
Once you have some potential clients,
you need to decide how much you're going to charge.
Maybe something reasonable like 1 million bucks or maybe it's Maybelline.
All right.
Jokes aside.
For each project,
you'll either charge an hourly rate or a fixed fee.
If you're a client wants to use a fixed rate for their project,
make sure to fully understand the scope of the project,
otherwise you'll risk being massively underpaid should the project run long or
requirements change.
It's best to start off with an hourly rate.
There are a lot of factors that go into deciding this rate,
like your location,
your level of experience,
and your skill set that can affect what you charge as an hourly rate.
So to help with this complexity,
you can use the online rate explorer@codementor.io to decide what you should
charge per hour.
And when you decided on an hourly rate,
don't ever go lower,
only raise it over time.
It may be hard at first to find a client,
but all it takes is one to validate your rate and the next ones will be easier
to get.
Earning freelance money is a liberating experience,
but you need to be sure that you stay organized financially.
With the freedom of freelancing comes the responsibility of managing finances,
your own finances,
and that means paying taxes yourself.
It's best for tax purposes to create a business bank account.
Instead of having it all go through your personal bank account,
it makes it easier to track your spending and earning and let you be more
thorough about budgeting.
Trust me on this one.
If you're serious about freelancing,
it is worth the effort to create a business bank account.
You will thank yourself when it's tax season.
A great tool to help with managing financial work is Hello Bonzai.
You can manage your proposals,
invoicing,
payments,
time tracking,
and more all from this one platform.
It's just a different way of living.
Similar to rising up the ranks at a company.
The longer you successfully do freelancing,
the more credibility you gain for your personal brand.
That means the more projects you successfully complete,
the better your reviews will be on freelance websites and the more work you can
showcase to future clients.
The best way to boost your marketability is to keep on building,
have projects on your get hub,
make sure your linkedin profile is up to date,
and have a personal website that links everything together.
It is absolutely crucial to have your own personal websites to showcase your
portfolio.
Use a simple code free tool like Weebly.
If you need to just make it happen and keep it technical.
Don't put on our band or on it or something.
Doing these things will make you prepared to begin the job hunt,
but ideally your clients come to you,
right?
One great way to do that is to showcase your technical expertise by developing
technical content.
That means a blog or a podcast or a youtube channel,
whatever.
Consistently make tutorials,
opinion pieces,
analyses of different topics in machine learning,
and you will slowly build a following.
The bigger your following,
the more people that will recommend you.
And all of this will add to your credibility.
As a brand.
I get more than enough requests to do consulting work because of the amount of
technical content I've pushed.
And so can you,
once you get started with the pirates life,
the navy is just way too boring.
Car Ipc jobs at this point and no matter how good the offer is,
I would never give up the freedom and flexibility of my lifestyle to work at a
corporation.
But remember you will need to master the art of self discipline to do this well.
You set your own hours,
you are your own boss.
So you also need to make sure to do things for yourself.
Like give yourself a vacation when you need it and wake up at a good time that
you decide it's hard at first.
But if you're consistent,
it becomes second nature.
Three things to remember from this video.
Freelancing is a perfectly viable career choice.
It gives you the freedom and flexibility to live the life you want,
but you'll need to master the art of self discipline.
You can use web tools to optimize your workflow from upwork,
Pew,
hello,
and to be successful,
you'll need to build your online presence by building projects for yourself and
for clients.
Plus,
building an audience through technical content definitely helps.
I've got a lot
Fredrickson here where it says crime in general.
For now,
I've got to put the pirates.